bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors on voit
que les démocrates ils maintiennent la
pression dans six pelosi qui demande à
ma pince d'invoquer la le 25e amendement
de la constitution des états unis
l'objectif il est clair pour les
démocrates c'est d'empêcher d'un hâle
train de se représenter dans quatre ans
oui bien sûr mais ils ont 48 heures
maintenant pour se réunir et pour
déclaré donald trump inapte à poursuivre
ses fonctions
alors donc il faut être rapide vont-ils
avoir honte y réussir à le faire le
mieux serait évidemment que donald trump
démissionne comme l'a fait nixon en 1973
mais je crois que donald trump
il n'acceptera pas de faire ça ce serait
vraiment abdiqué il n'acceptera pas et
quant à la procédure d' impeachment
c'est encore beaucoup plus compliqué
parce que ils n'ont pas le temps en 12
jours maintenant d'appliquer cette de
d'engager la procédure et de la faire
appliquer avant l'investiture du 20
janvier
bon évidemment la procédure peut
continuer après l'investiture et de joe
biden s'est très c'est une situation
très complexe
ça peut vouloir dire que à la suite
justement l'investiture de joe biden il
peut y avoir des suites judiciaires
oui bien sûr bien sûr les suites
judiciaires
les suites judiciaires auront lieu bien
sûr parce qu'il y a le problème
politique mais il y à toutes les
affaires personnelles de donald trump
de toute façon il est évident on
qu'ensuite il ne sera pas tranquille
mais ce qui importe pour le moment et
pour les américains c'est cette
procédure de destitution
ou bien donc cette émission le plus
simple est la procédure la plus rapide
est celle du 25e a maintenant alors il
est il est aux états unis le quatrième à
être concernée par la procédure d'
impeachment
n'a jamais été appliquée le premier
était andrew johnson qui a succédé au
président lincoln assassiné
il n'a pas finalement il n'a pas été
destituée la procédure d' impeachment
n'a pas été appliquée parce qu'il
n'avait pas eu le temps de nommer un
vice-président et c'était donc le
président pauthe en port du sénat qui
devait lui succéder
mais il était encore beaucoup plus
radicale quand drew johnson donc andrew
johnson n'a pas n'a pas été frappé de la
procédure d' impeachment pour richard
nixon
elle n'a pas été appliquée non plus
puisqu'il a démissionné pour bill
clinton elle n'a pas été appliquée ce
n'était pas suffisant
alors maintenant c'est là la quatrième
expérience est ce qu'elle va être lancée
est-ce qu'elle ira à son terme si elle
va à son terme ce sera après
l'investiture de joe biden la question
maintenant c'est de savoir l'avenir
politique de john pour donald trump
on le sent lâché de plus en plus par a
le camp républicain
là dessus qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur son avenir politique
son avenir politique est quand même très
compromis alors je ne peux pas et il est
évident que s'il est frappé de la
procédure d' impeachment il n'aura il
aura perdu toute toute possibilité
éligibles et il ne sera plus jamais lui
n'aura plus de carrière politique
alors c'est vrai que même les
républicains maintenant sont favorables
son départ ce qui est étonnant parce que
lors de la première procédure d'
impeachment le peuple américain ne
voulez pas que l'amérique car n'était
pas d'accord avec cette procédure il ne
voulait pas son départ mais maintenant
la majorité augmente chaque jour aussi
bien dans le camp des démocrates que
dans le camp des républicains il est
lâché par les siens
on parlera de l'avenir politique de
donald trams mais aussi à l'avenir
politique finalement l'avenir du camp
républicain on sait qu'aux états unis il
ya un fort clivage politique démocrate
républicain les conséquences pour son
parti justement de toute cette affaire
les conséquences
alors c'est très jeu ne peux pas me
projeter
je suis sereine je vois le passé je ne
vois pas l'avenir parce que tout est
extrêmement fragile et qu'il pouvait
prévoir cette manifestation un terrible
au capitole c'est la première fois que
ça se produit en plus ça bouleverse
complètement l'investiture parce qu'il
n'y aura pas la parade comme d'habitude
il y aura un service d'ordre
un colossal comment ça va se passer
surtout cette passation il a dit qu'il
ne serait pas là ce qui est extrêmement
grave pour le pays ce qui puisqu'il ne
sera pas là ça veut dire qu'il ne sera
pas présent au capitole et normalement
il ne sera pas présent à washington
que peut-il se passer à ce moment là
alors c'est ça l'avenir très très proche
qui se dessine et qui est très
inquiétant pour le parti républicain
peut-être et sur les tensions
aux états unis on sait que il ya
toujours ce face à face entre les pro et
les anti trump c'est peut-être du jamais
vu dans l'histoire politique américaine
oui c'est certain parce que il ya ce
mouvement cannon qui est très très
radicale qui prend de plus en plus
d'importance pas seulement aux états
unis dans le monde
ils ont réussi à faire croire à cette à
ce complot lors du scrutin
et si dans un mouvement qui s'est
propagée vous rencontrer sans cesse des
gens qui vous disent au bout mais il ya
une machination
on lui a volé son oncle voler son
élection lui il a fait croire ce set
cette fable mais il faut se souvenir que
en 2016 hillary clinton avait davantage
de voix que lui lui il l'emportait
l'élection parce qu'il avait les grands
électeurs mais ça s'est joué
très très peu de choses et hillary
clinton avait davantage de voix que lui
comme al gore en 1980 mais aussi bien al
gore que hillary clinton ont n'ont pas
insisté et l'on préférait reconnaître la
victoire de leurs adversaires hillary
clinton a reconnu la victoire de donald
trump alors qu'elle avait pour elle le
le vote populaire
donc là maintenant les républicains sont
de plus en plus conservateur ils sont
guidés
ils sont intoxiqués ils sont par ce
mouvement
cannon qui est très violent et qui
quitte une aubaine pour tous les
radicaux république a et c'est ça qui
est dommage parce que là l'opposition va
être extrêmement dur parce que joe biden
aura la majorité au sénat mais c'est une
majorité très faible qui sera le fait du
vote de kamala harris
donc il devra compter avec les
américains merci beaucoup à vous régime
de rentes je rappelle que vous êtes
historienne spécialiste des états unis